Okay, so this payroll is going to start on Monday, October 27th, 2025 and end on November
2nd, 2025.
So Monday AM shift, it was John Neal and before tip out he made $72.32 and the tip
out to Cobin needs to be $10.
So those tips that I just gave you are the before tip out.
So again, John was $72.32 and then need to tip out Cobin $10.
Now for Monday night, the PM shift, these are final numbers.
Austin Kelly $200.88, Janelle Bakke $200.88, Maddox Porter $63.64.
Okay and that is it for Monday.
So I think, okay now on to the Tuesday, October 28th AM shift.
Again it was John Neal and these are going to be and this is a before tip out tip number
I'm going to give you.
So John made $61.72 and then we need to tip out Cobin Cross $13.
Okay and then what I'm about to give you is before tip out again.
So we need to calculate it.
Austin and Kevin before tip out should have each made $192.45.
And then Maddox needs to be tipped out $38.03.
Okay, now we're doing Wednesday AM shift, John Neal was the server again.
No tip out.
So the final tips for John Neal should have been $233.96.
And then Wednesday, October 29th, 2025 for the PM shift.
These are the final numbers.
Janelle made $50.22, Heather made $50.22, Cobin made $21.25.
So those are all the after tip out numbers.
Okay, now for the Thursday morning shift.
It was Austin Kelly was our server slash bartender.
There was no tip out on this one.
So this tip number is the final amount $169.10.
Okay, and now let's do Thursday PM.
It was just Austin Kelly.
And before tip out, he made $321.82.
And he needed to tip out Maddox Porter $50.27.
So we'll need to subtract that from that $321.82 number to get the final tips.
Okay, so now Friday AM, it was just Austin Kelly solo.
And there's no tip out.
So his final tip number should be $311.25.
So now we're doing Friday PM.
And so here are the final numbers.
Kevin and Austin, each made $214.35.
Maddox needs to be tipped out $44.27.
So again, those were just the final numbers for Friday PM.
Okay, and now we're doing Saturday, November 1st, 2025, starting with the AM shift.
It was Kevin and Mark tip pooling with no tip out.
So their final tip numbers, they need to get $163.41 each for Saturday, 11-1-25 AM shift.
Kevin Worley and Mark Baryanek.
Okay, Saturday, 11-1-25 PM shift.
Okay, and these are the final numbers.
Kevin and Mark each needed to make $191.18.
Or that's what they each made, $191.18.
Again, after tipping out, Cobin $54.31.
So those are the final numbers.
Okay, now we're doing Sunday AM shift.
Again, that was November 2nd, 2025.
So here are the final numbers.
Our bartender slash servers were Kevin Worley and Mike Walton.
Each of them, after tip out, need to make $82.95.
And then the tip out should go to Cobin Cross, and that tip out should be $29.01.
Okay, and now to finish us off for the Sunday, November 2nd, 2025 PM shift.
And these are the final numbers, because even Kevin started giving me the final numbers.
So Kevin and Mike Walton were the server slash bartenders.
They each made $114.74.
And again, that's their final tip numbers after tipping out Cobin.
A total of $39.97.